[Music]
in the savannahs of kenya
two female northern white rhinos nayin
and fatu munch contentedly on the grass
at the time of this video's publication
these are the last two
known northern white rhinos left on
earth
their species is functionally extinct
without a male
nayin and fatu can't reproduce and yet
there's still hope to revive the
northern white rhino
how can that be the story starts about
50 years ago
when poachers began illegally hunting
thousands of rhinos across africa
for their horns this combined with civil
wars in their territory
decimated northern white rhino
populations
concerned conservationists began trying
to breed them in captivity
in the 1970s collecting and storing
semen from males only four rhinos were
ultimately born through the ambitious
breeding program
nyan and her daughter fatu were the last
two
in 2014 conservationists discovered
that neither can have a calf though nyan
gave
birth to fatu she now has weak hind legs
which could harm her health if she
became pregnant again
fatu meanwhile has a degenerated uterine
lining
then the last northern white rhino male
of the species
sudan died in 2018
but there was one glimmer of hope
artificial reproduction
with no living males and no females able
to carry a pregnancy
this is a complicated and risky process
to say the least
though scientists had stored semen they
would have to collect
the eggs a complex procedure that
requires a female to be sedated
for up to two hours then they'd create a
viable embryo in the lab
something that had never been done
before and no one knew how to do
even that was just the beginning a
surrogate mother
of another rhino species would have to
carry the embryo to term
females of a closely related species the
southern white rhino
became both the key to developing a
rhino embryo in a lab
and the leading candidates for surrogate
mothers
northern and southern white rhinos
diverged about a million years ago
into separate though still closely
related species
they inhabit different regions and have
slightly different
physical traits in a fortunate
coincidence
several female southern white rhinos
needed treatment for their own
reproductive problems
and researchers could collect eggs as
part of that treatment
in devore kralove zoo in october 2015
experts of izw berlin began collecting
eggs from southern white rhinos
and sending them to avantia an animal
reproduction laboratory in italy
there scientists developed and perfected
a technique to create
a viable embryo once they mastered the
technique
researchers extracted nyan and fatu's
eggs
on august 22 2019 and flew them to italy
three days later they fertilized the
eggs with sperm
from a northern white rhino male after
another week
two of the eggs made it to the stage of
development when the embryo can be
frozen
and preserved for the future another
collection in december 2019
produced one more embryo as of early
the plan is to collect nayin and fatu's
eggs
three times a year if they're healthy
enough
in the meantime researchers are looking
for promising southern white rhino
surrogate mothers
ideally who've carried a pregnancy to
term before
the surrogacy plan is somewhat of a leap
of faith
southern and northern white rhinos have
interbred both
during the last glacial period and more
recently in 1977
so researchers are optimistic a southern
white rhino would be able to carry a
northern white rhino to term
also the two species pregnancies are the
same length
still transferring an embryo to a rhino
is tricky because of the shape of the
cervix
the ultimate goal which will take
decades is to establish a breeding
population
of northern white rhinos in their
original range
studies suggest that we have samples
from enough individuals
to recreate a population with the
genetic diversity the species had
a century ago though the specifics of
this effort are unique
as more species face critical
endangerment or functional extinction
it's also an arena for big questions
do we have a responsibility to try to
bring species back from the brink
especially when human actions brought
them there in the first place
are there limits to the effort we should
expend on
saving animals threatened with
extinction
[Music]
how are conservationists and communities
helping endangered species recover
see how some regions are working to
repopulate vulture communities
by opening vulture restaurants with this
video
or explore how we can sustainably farm
the ocean
to prevent overfishing with this video